each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
everyone let's uh let's return to our
seats okay so yeah Mateus do you stay at
the front mr. Smigiel okay so now we
have Matthias Troyer welcome back after
lunch Matthias Troy is going to speak to
us about classical versus quantum
annealing so we'll just turn it over to
my tias thank you and I first want to
clarify one thing namely people were
confused this week whether I'm a
physicist to an engineer of a computer
scientist and I have documented evidence
from UCSB that I'm an experimental
marine biologist Ella stop using to that
but I'm not talk about the media lets me
do in science and that but I I will not
talk total but I talk about felt
layer continent and eating and before I
go there I want to ask if anybody here
is not familiar with what the quantum
annealer is about the d-wave devices or
have you all heard me talk 20 times on
that if there's somebody who's not
familiar they should shout because I
talk on recently work that I would call
this d-wave inspired recent papers and
recent something at work in progress and
on Wednesday I showed all red TS a
slight but there are tvs it's a
quantum annealer it solves the cuba
problem or a distinct last problem and
one key result is that we so far could
not observe any evidence for quantum
speed-up in a quantum annealer and one
question that I want to answer is why
that might be the case
in the the basic question in quantum it
really is can we solve an optimization
problem faster by quantum tunneling
through a barrier than by classically
good con- me up to over it but one can
do more one can also simulate the
quantum mechanical tunneling through it
and in the case of de- take the icing
spin class you take the the the mayor
problem Hamiltonian and the code did did
did dat with cubits you add the
theater then I got a tensor field you
start with a strong transverse field you
a diabetic Lee change it you ramp down
the field you ramp up the couplings and
you find the ground state of your
problem you can do that in many need
negative inversions in the ground state
coherently eight telepathically that's
the the the layer now quantum 8t
diabatic method by adding others you can
do it let me up to find a temperature in
experiments fast and so on that's
quantum annealing it it's the flexible
approach you do something like it and
hope you win you can also simulate it on
a classical computer and that we call
simulated quantum annealing like with
but that's where Eddie has a problem
when you call it that way so let me show
you that similarly quantum annealer can
actually mean many different things it's
just I'm doing something like quantum
annealing on a classical computer it's a
classical algorithm just like quantum
Monte Carlo is a classical algorithm
which people in quantum
formation hate that we miss represented
as quantum of the color is actually
classical so here one thing you might
think of when you do when you simulate a
quantity like you could think you
actually simulate the quantum manila so
you simulate either the unitary
evolution or the the open your
systems dynamics of the quantum annealer
you can also do a simulation of
something that mimics quantum annealing
for example you think think negative on
the car lot I dynamics and one should
just be clear what we mean and I will
show the evidence later that one can
learn things about a quantum annealer
from a simulated quantum annealer but
similarly for simulate economy can refer
to many things if you want to say it is
unitary quantum annealing then I would
call it you bash QA that's my proposal
or an open system have here many
different acronyms for you that's what
this light is about so when I talk about
similarly quantum annealing then I will
mostly mean qmc QA yeah Shin small and
Smith I call that Monte Carlo quantum
annealing care or a mean-field cuando
making any way you could call it MF q MC
cool I all whatever but ken can many HSA
to somewhere to some algorithm and it's
not a quantum annealer that I simulate
but I do a simulation something that is
like quantum annealing like quantum of
the card is not the quantum algorithm
but it's monte carlo of a quantum system
so i think as long as we're clear what
you mean that's good but i will now make
statements based on quanta monte carlo
about what the quantum annealer might do
and that's the end that I have to like
to show you why that actually makes
sense but first when we compare the TTD
wave to to a
from the st. elevation we look at the
wrong times just for the pure kneeling
the times are comparable I don't care
about the factor thousand faster slower
it's comparable that's quite good but
it's not the interesting fashion the
interesting question is more how do the
times to solution scale and if we look
just at the intrinsic times and look for
example at the typically instance so the
median here and the scaling for large
problem instances also for the higher
quantized it's similar for classic Anila
and 4d wave if we then calculate the
speed up then we see that for the the
typically instance the ratio of the
scale of the times is about constant for
the harder instances the higher quantile
there's some slowdown and that's bad
news I wanted to really see a speeder
because bed will has been exciting but
the interesting question that I want to
address nice why did we not see the
speed up that we expected and they could
be due to the calibration errors it
could just be that we looked at the
wrong problems you might have looked at
the problems which that just is nocando
speed up and we should look should have
looked at better problems it might have
been to tool pet cubits or it's just a
bad machine as some people claim but
basically the ultimate question that
bothered me is why did Monte Carlo
simulations published previously show
evidence for quantum annealing
outperforming classical annealing when
we did not see that on T wave they
showed that when you run the quantum
Monte Carlo simulated quantum annealing
you find a low energy state faster with
better scaling than a classical annealer
on d way if we did not see that we did
not even see that in our quantum of the
carlo simulation so there was a problem
here
so when we looked at the test educated
the scaling for the native problems on T
wife we found that quantum Monte Carlo
and in and with me the d-wave the
scaling was similar for the hardest
problems we never found the ground state
the others is scaled in roughly the same
way we also to so never found it with
quantum of the color by the way yes two
different quantites clean is the median
time that is the 95th percentile black
the 99th dark blue the first percentile
so you see that a huge spread is where
by a factor of 10,000 and more between
the easy problem and the hard ones and
the scaling is a bit steeper for the
taunton approaches sorry that's my wife
who wants to talk to me but you have to
wait Annabeth and it's never and it's
better scaling with classical annealing
these are the time to solution that as
the time to find the solution with 99
percent probability doesn't mean x time
look similar and we see that it's worse
with quantum of the color QA and made it
explicit for Eddie and and for the
classic annealing I need to and here's
the evidence why it should have been
better they looked at the two distinct
glass they found that ok that's a big
instance they lowered now they 1550
yielded with a classical annealer here
in black open sir the closed circles
with the quantum annealer the open
circles and they found the energy drops
down much faster scales better with the
simulated
quantum Anita they even called it Q a
quantum annealing addy so that was why
we believe that it's actually better
because there was this evidence now they
showed already that for okay but this is
not what we saw on d wife they showed
already that fog reset problem it looks
different for three set the classically
kneeling is better than the you simulate
the quantum annealing and we wanted to
understand that and there were three
different first of all they looked at a
slightly different lattice there n it
slightly differently with a slightly
different algorithm on a single instance
we compared the rejected using their
algorithm on the instance we totally
reproduce it and we found out what
happens and for that I need to explain
how we do quantum of the color when we
do classic about the color we have a
lattice the spins we flip them randomly
and sample the position function and we
slowly cool down the system when we do
quantum Monte Carlo the partition
function is not just the sum over
classical configurations but we can map
it to a negative test the path integral
take many copies of them and the weight
of a configuration of the path integral
is that of a three-dimensional Ising
model so quantum of the column means we
do classic monte carlo on the path
integral which are the configurations
now offer 3d instead of a 2d Ising model
and that we can do and when we do it
that way then it works beautifully but
in order to me to do it one use to
discretize the imaginary time direction
but sometimes step and the argument was
always the universal properties of your
system should not
depend on the value of the time step is
a sin yeah relevant perturbation if you
go to a cuddly point that should not
matter so here the the solution about
why things different comes up
immediately when you start looking okay
it's was not immediately it was after a
few month once we started looking at
what is the dependence on the time step
that we choose and what happens when
they take more and more and more finer
time slices and here i show the
performance of the quantum any of this
simulated quantum annealer at the fixed
temperature as we are changing the
number of time slices when it's just one
then it's very bad we take more and more
and more we get to about 20 that's the
this line here this is what they saw
before and it goes down rapidly but then
we can increase it further when we
increase it further we take smaller
smaller smaller time steps it gets
better by the impaired and better at
first and get stuck we get down faster
to some good state and then we get stuck
now what that tells you is okay this is
also and this is also what with Sundy
wave and when we compared we took a tiny
tiny times x then we saw the class any
levels working worse then yeah so the
class anillos working better the d-wave
and better than the quantum of the color
so now this does not tell you that the
results are wrong but they're just two
different ways of running a simulated
quantum annealer if you want to run it
as a classical optimization algorithm
then that gives you a way to actually
optimize the performance of this
classical algorithm if you want to go to
as low energy as possible then you
should not use the tiny time step you
should use a large time step how can you
understand that how can a large time
step
a large solar time step how can that
improve the performance of the algorithm
over that of a physical system and the
answer is simple let's introduce here
for the room at times tube of 10 seconds
and i will quantum tunneling through the
wall because during the time step i ask
you to close your eyes and when you open
the eyes again after one time step I'll
be outside and I've walked through a
closed door close your eyes yeah so that
that's what's going on by having the
large time step I can flip multiple
spins at once between the one replica
and the next ones and I don't have to
build up the term idiot state that would
cost energy on the top of the barrier
but I can go through it in one time step
that makes for a better classical
algorithm but this is trick that they
cannot reproduce in a physical device
where I can because the large times the
basically means I'm doing it with a
different nagar Hamiltonian again which
he would be one which has has their
nagar planted multiple the spin flip
term but with local spin flips I can't
have to go through a state that's in the
barrier and pay the penalty classically
in Monte Carlo I can avoid that by
taking a large time step and if we then
optimize the temperature and the time
step size then we get that the best
scaling of the simulated quantum
annealer is better than that of the
classical annealer but if we go to the
physical limit of the time step going to
0 then this is the performance of the
simulated your quantum Neela ok drops
down a bit faster then it's it weapons
out in the classical annealer ultimately
scales better
now it was argued by cut scrubber and by
the t-wave later also that for two
distinct last one would never have
expected a quantum speed-up now that's
surprising because T we've also used
them to show the speed up but we learn
we all learn and indeed to the spring
classes might be a bad choice because in
the two distinct last the critical
temperature Sara meaning a tiny bit of
energy that you add a little bit of
temperature allows you to escape a
minimum so the bag is are probably not
very high and when they are not very
tall the barriers then one can get out
efficiently thermally the argument then
was if one goes to a 3ds Bing loss with
a large critical temperature and tall
bear yes that that are extensive that
should be the point where you should
look for cuanto speed art we didn't see
it on d wave and in the simulations in
3d unfortunately we see the same the
classic annealing is here the vet curve
and the quantum Monte Carlo and Neela's
or get stuck and ultimately scale worse
so the lessons learned here it's
simulated quantum annealing cannot only
refer to different algorithms but even
for quantum Monte Carlo we can perform
it in two different ways we can either
cheat take a large time step we have a
quantum inspired classical algorithm
that outperforms the quantum of the
color in the physical limit so if you
want to have a good classic lob team
ization algorithm use the large time
step if you want to predict what a
quantum device might do that does
quantum annealing let the time step go
to Sarah we're still looking for
problems that show quantum speed-up in
that case but now we know exactly how we
should look for something that shows
potential
second part heavy tales you saw this big
spirit of effect of 10,000 and more for
the quantum in India the question yes to
that yes no bills effectively we have
them in yes so what was added into that
wave or somewhere else that you could
guess we have think could do you like
that yes it helps but it helps only by
constant as long as you add only yeah
and then you have to 2 cubed cup landed
at lickable couple other it it helps yes
now this huge scatter here because we
care about solving hard problems now I
show just at one size here where we can
still solve it always with quantum of
the color the distribution of how many
times have to run the simulated nila all
simulated quantum annealer to actually
find the ground state this is not for
the biggest problem sizes but for
something with 288 spins its it has a
power-law tail this the lock
scales here and that's one instance we
need to do about ten thousand
repetitions with the classic vanilla the
typically one is about order 10 the easy
ones are or the one when you spend a
gift ear and a problem you don't know
whether it's hard or easy so if you want
to solve all of them or most of them
then you should assume it might be hard
and you have to run them all 10,000
times because we don't know how to
actually predict whether it's easy or
hard with a simulated quantum neyland we
see the same scaling on the wave we find
that the hardest instance we had to run
about
a few billion times to find the ground
state that's the hardest out of ten
thousand so okay it's quite hard but
it's not extremely hard the hard to test
out of a thousand that's about here you
still have learned about the million
times the easy problems you run once
boom you are there so what should you do
to improve it you have to have it slower
to find it right to get more idiopathic
what actually not one can also try to
manage faster and here's what happens
when one runs it faster when we run it
faster and now we run it about 66 times
faster we do just 150 updates per spin
so extremely fast yes we never solve it
in one step anymore we have to attempt
at least twice the 2.1 also goes up for
maybe five to six times repetitions but
and doing much faster once and the
surprisingly site is that the hard work
is now for just two hundred was easier
to play with instead of 10 million
repetitions the hard one succeeds in
about twenty thousand repetitions so
when we run it faster we only 66 times
faster and for the hardest test problem
of 10,000 we actually need 688 times
fewer repetitions leather each 66 times
faster for speed up of nearly 50,000 so
what that tells us is that it it's more
than just saying we have to run it
idiopathic this lowly but one has to
think a bit more about what one is doing
a thing kind of what is the best player
schedule and the hard problems they
shall stuck in some local minimum I ran
into it and then have to tunnel out of
it into the two global minimum and there
are two ways of doing that one way is
to learn it much much slower to be a tea
party maybe at much lower temperature
with much better cubits to really adapt
ethically tunnel through this heart
barrier or the other way is I just ran
as fast and I just kick it out of the
minimum and it has a better chance of
finding the two-count state and less
similar love love such were found by TD
idea Ian discontented to the 32
collaborators so once you turn it faster
and we have to find out here what is the
best way of running it but don't run it
adiabatically slowly that's one lesson
we learned the other interesting thing
is when you look at the tails the they
can either be finite they can be
exponential all have this negative
tested power law which is a
characterized pop pop by and you have to
exponent sigh here and we plot now how
that changes as a function of problem
size and we see that as we go up in the
problem size for the classical annealer
it gets close to about a half and
slightly bigger now a half means the
power is about to e it's neg a pepto 10
walks I and when it reaches one that it
means that the variance is no longer
defined because the second moment
diverges so you can't just sample ikat
the meantime because the meantime has an
infinite error but what's worse is when
it gets above one which for the quantum
annealer happens the size of about
seventy-two already then the meantime is
not defined anymore because the first
moment the mean actually diverges
meaning if you were to calculate the
mean time is totally dominated by the
hardest instance and the mean is
infinite
so that's why we put always the median
and not the mean but if the hardest
instances dominated and there's bad news
but when you run it faster then we see
that actually the tails are very similar
they are heavy but it's not worse with
quantum annealing than with classic
annealing this is this side parameter
it's the that's near the theater but one
over the power in the distribution
function so when it's one we don't have
to mean anymore so it looks better here
there's still those hard instances
extremely events but it's now the same
here so one has to look at these tales
and not just at the median and going
slowly might not be optimal that was the
second lesson we learned we have to
really optimize 50 kneeling times for
the hard problems so with that we can
now think of which problems and which
design and which hardware graph could be
good to actually see quantum speed-up
but then okay and that's what we're
trying and we are still looking for
problems that have quantum speed-up and
looking for that and not finding such
problems and finding that all the
problems with trying actually have
problems one starts worrying and one way
out could be if quantum of the color
doesn't tell you anything about reality
so the people ask us okay okay yeah you
don't find any quantum speed-up with
quantum of the color but what does
fundamental have to do with the real
time evolution of a quantum system and a
first sight it has nothing to do with it
the one is a stochastic lee sample apart
integral I do fit the test elastic
updates the other is I take away
function that they evolve coherently and
that is totally different dynamics and
yes I completely agree it's very
different dynamics for the same physical
system and I'm arguing this that for the
problems with with high barriers there
is a deep relationship and that
relationship comes from the fact that
going through a barrier going from one
side going from here to here and
tunneling fluid is rate limited by the
same physics namely have the same
quantum system I have to go through that
barrier after tunnel of who and it's the
tunneling process that limits the time I
need and it is the same rate limiting
physics in the quantum of the color
dynamics and in the quantum annealer one
might argue that at a quantum critical
point the standby son Ricky says at the
quantum clearly point we know that
quantum Monte Carlo has a different
dynamic exponent than the physical
system and that's correct yes I fully
agree and we designed quantum Monte
Carlo methods to actually a equal plate
faster than the physical system but
what's more important here is that we're
not sitting at a quantum critical point
in looking at the longtime dynamics I
want to go just through a barrier and
when you look at the spin glass then the
first you have a quantum critical point
is the function of the titted the
transverse field that separates the term
magnet from the sprinklers face and
there the gate closes typically with the
power law then inside the spin glass
face there are more level crossings or
white lead level crossings with an
exponentially closing gap
and those are the heart bottlenecks that
we have to go through where to get a
tunnel through a barrier with an
exponentially small gap this is nothing
to do with the quantum critical point so
what we now want it to look at what is
the relationship between the tunneling
through such a barrier in quantum of the
color compared to the unit target the
dynamics in the quantum system we know
the time goes like 1 over the gap
squared what happens in quantum of the
color and the first problem we looked at
it was just just the negative 27 magnet
we looked at the chain we looked at a
cluster that be coupled and say okay
what is the time that I need to go from
all spins up to the spins flipping down
from one side to the other day of the
area and how does it scale and the
splitting between the 50 states is the
gap we calculate the gap and we know how
the physical dynamic scales quantum
Monte Carlo I have my word line and a
tunnel not by flipping the spins of
paying here think the technical energy I
start by flipping them just for a very
short time interval when I do this
as the apart in a double well I flip a
jump from the right to the left and back
and I create the kinky and the
negativity and enter kink kink
here in the the word lines and the rate
limiting factor is have to create this
instant on and the entire visit instant
on and then now measure the time and
need to actually go into that transition
state and then check how it's kate's
and here is the data for various system
sizes various strengths of the
transverse field the open symbols are
the time scale that comes from the
quantum of the color the closed symbols
is one over the gap squared and the
agreement it's just the same scaling so
in this problem the scaling is the same
in quantum of the color as for the
physical dynamics and it's basically I'm
here how can Kevin negahban loft the
minima and I jump over with the kink and
the enter kink and they pay the cost of
two instantons have to go there and have
to go back because of to close the trace
in imaginary time and that gives me then
the delta squared scaling but there's a
variant of quantum of the color that is
called cold for check the
Montecarlo right just start from a tile
state and I put checked out the ground
state from a fixed trial state or what
it means basically is I take the path
integral and I make the boundaries open
I don't close the taste I just leave the
boundaries open when they leave the
boundaries open then the trajectory can
start in one minimum can tunnel through
and end up in the other minimum now I
paid the cost only of one instant on
it's only half the cost and one would
not expect that the rate should be
faster it should be the square or the
end okay so and the time Indian turns
out now the time scales beautifully with
one over the gap instead of one of a gap
squared so with the
the periodic boundary conditions I
find the same scaling as a physical
cuanto anila but in quantum Monte Carlo
I can cheat by cutting open the place
and then I can scale better indicator
quadratics beat up for the simulated
quantum annealer for the classical
algorithm over the quantum approach now
this is for the tunneling through a
barrier what about the global search
problem because now I could say hey but
now I am saying similarly colony lab
works better than physical quantum
annealer so should we give up and the
answer no maybe not because that's all
so but I think what this shows is that
just saying that we can handle more
easily through a barrier than climbing
over it and that's why quantum annealer
is better this is just the wrong picture
because for this tunneling micron de
monte carlo called scales better than
any quantum annealer but if we look at
the search problem then the problem is
actually finding the other state and in
the global problem the gap closes the
legs 1 over root n which with the
quantum adiabatic technica theorem would
give you a scaling with the number of
states the quantum Monte Carlo no matter
where they do my clicks are not I just
have to find that state and that time
just has to be proportional to the
number of possible states I take a go to
so it's proportional to n no matter what
I do the cutting things open does not
help because now I'm searching and not
tunneling now for all we know if or if I
choose an optimal annealing schedule
then it can get the time down to one
over gap so can outperform it but that
requires two ingredients that are not
generic I have to know the exact
analytical form of the gap and
the gap is not allowed to depend on the
solution for the puke of a problem we
know that for no other problem do we
know it so the generic search type
problem it's one of a gap squared and it
scales just like want a Monte Carlo put
so with that let's think again about
what does this imply for quantum
annealing first of all I think it shows
that if you're limited by the tunneling
flip area or if you're limited by
searching then the simulated quantum
annealer is actually a gala is actually
a good indicator for the performance of
a to quantum annealing the scaling for
the test attended the scaling is the
same for the cover type problem in the
test instead generic case the scaling is
the same for the flipping of spins for
going through air barrier in the case of
the tunneling flip area it can it can
even make it faster now does that mean
that something like d-wave can never
work that we should stop building a
quantum annealer that we should put
forget about that and be happy that we
have now very fast quantum inspired
anila man's it's it's a bit too early
for that because I still want to check
how does it look like for Paris since
been glasses rechecking think that now
we have our documents that it should
scale generically in the same way when
you have petal payers so that the
leading term term the x-ray is the same
as long as the gap becomes a porn and
Chile small but in a quantum annealer
you can also make it the non stochastic
when you make it non stochastic then
there's no quantum of the cover metric
could map it to so now you have a
quantum annealer that I can simulate and
you can simulate the stochastic version
of it but now the question is can
I make it perform more efficiently by
adding dynamics that's non stochastic
and I don't think we know the answer yet
that's one thing to explore and then
we'll probably if we wanted on a big
system that will mean we have to build a
nice coherent quantum annealer with non
stochastic terms so yes we should build
one just to answer that question the
next one is that my tastings had the
paper way showed that generically
quantum Monte Carlo dynamics can be much
much lower can be exponentially slower
than a quantum annealer these arguments
were first of all for a problem where
there's a large gap that stays large in
which case he made problems where the
quantum Monte Carlo can get
exponentially stuck in some topological
sector somewhere like having winding
numbers but by cutting open the temporal
boundary conditions that's easy he still
constructed other problems we are adding
more states to it but might be able to
one might be stuck that's what we have
to look into where do do this any
problems occur are they really they're
in real problems and where can we find
the problem but we see a big difference
so here these are more questions than
answers now but to make sure that the
quantum O'Neill is worth a building I
think we have to now look for reasons
for ways to outperform our quadratic
classical speed up so the summary is
watch the time steps beware of the tails
and when it tunnels through barriers you
better do it quantum inspired thank you
questions for Matias
right yeah
so besides big fat barriers there's also
the problem that has been analyzed where
you have like lots of like thin spikes
like you kind of have to go through a
comb of narrow barriers but there's just
a lot of them and like canta me a better
computer can get like stuck in those
cases to do you have any sense if
quantum Monte Carlo how it's going to
deal with that kind of situation Eddie
might know what I'm talking about so you
have lots of spikes of fixed height or
flowing height yeah um yes ok I don't
know I i think if the if the tunnel
array through the spikes could gets
smaller as I increase the problem sighs
and then similar web when I just get
more spikes no no I don't know but it
would be period be nice to find such a
problem now in the spin glasses they're
being a humans that the number of
spikes should go with the log of the
problem size so it's not many it's very
very few in fact it's just logon
barriers that you go through and I don't
know any kind of spin problem we could
try that has so many barriers if you
find one I happen then please tell me
because I want to find a reason to kill
my arguments here please help me
great let's think Matthias one more time